well we're joined Now by The Shadow
leveling up secretary Lisa Nando thank
you for being with us and we've just
been listening to the Jacob re small
interview I was quite interested what he
said about the working week the 48 hour
week as some regulation we should look
at all different regulations
particularly those under EU law do you
agree with him I I didn't hear the
precise thing that he said about the
48-hour week but I certainly got the
general thrust that this is a government
that is going to try to deregulate in
order to fuel growth in the economy I
think the problem for them is that a lot
of these ideas have been tried before
we've already had Rishi sunak for
example trying to scrap or lower stamp
Duty during the pandemic it just pushed
up house prices it didn't help
first-time buyers in fact there was
quite a bit of evidence that it made
housing affordability worse I think the
government really does need to think
seriously about not just what help
they're going to provide but who pays
for that help that was the big
unanswered question from that interview
that you just did with the business
secretary everybody accepts that
businesses families need help this
winter the question is are we going to
tax the profits of people who've done
well in the last few years or are we
going to load more and more of that cost
onto struggling small businesses and
struggling families across the country
as you say it is an unanswered question
still we are asking it Jacob reesman
says look we've got to wait till Friday
which I guess is two days away
um to find out exactly how they do a
plan to pay from it and what else are
you looking forward for on Friday well
we've got we've got to have a plan to
help people now and we've got to make
sure that the burden falls on those who
are most able to Bear it so you know as
we put forward plans to raise the
digital sales tax for example so that
the big internet Giants pay a bit more
we think that would raise about two
billion pounds we could use half of that
to help energy intensive Industries who
are really struggling right now and the
other half as a fund to raise the
threshold for business rates relief so
that a lot of small businesses will be
taken out of business business rates
altogether and others would find that
they had help with other costs at a time
when Energy prices are soaring those are
the sort of proposals that we want to
see the government bringing forward not
more of this loading more of the costs
displacing them onto businesses and
families who are already struggling by
higher taxis for a very long period of
time we want to see fairness in the
system and that's what the government
has to answer I mean I guess what
they're trying to do with business isn't
it is to try and remove some of that tax
burden as well particularly in this the
uh the investment zones as well
potentially slashing taxes for business
and even potentially for workers as well
in deprived areas to try and boost
growth is that something you think would
be a good idea well this isn't a new
idea so this is an idea that's been
around for a very long time it was tried
under the last Labor government George
Osborne it was his big idea in 2011 and
we've still got a lot of these they're
called Enterprise zones at the moment
they're being renamed investment zones
the problem with what the government is
briefing is that these are not
particularly focused on deprived areas
and the areas that have them don't
necessarily benefit doesn't seem that
they'll get to keep any proceeds of
growth that are developed there and if
if what Jacob Reese MOG was hinting at
is what eventually materializes the
situation for people in these zones
could get far far worse if you're
essentially saying to some businesses
you can come in you won't pay any taxes
other businesses are going to have to
take the strain you're going to displace
the amount of tax burden on some other
businesses but also you're gonna you're
gonna cause real problems because if
they're not paying towards the
infrastructure in those places for the
roads and the the schools and all of the
things that sustain a place who is going
to pay for it it's probably going to be
taxpayers so you know government needs
to think really seriously about this
because they've been warned by every
senior Economist that the plans that
they're currently briefing out aren't
going to create the growth that they
need I uh just wonder though when they
were talking about growth there the one
thing you can say about this government
is we know what they stand for growth
right you can sum up in a word we can
argue about whether or not it's going to
be effective or if it's going to work or
not but we know the policy principle
that they stand for every policy is
around that what does labor stand for
look we've been pushing the government
to get a growth strategy since the
beginning so growth is that what you
stand for but but but actually Sophie I
would question this because I you know I
went into the first prime minister's
questions with listro so I think it was
absolutely clear who she stood for she
stands for the few and not the many
that's why she's loading the cost of the
energy proposals onto people and
hard-working families not onto the
office of everyone and we could have
obviously there is clearly a debate
about whether or not that is true or not
but we know that this is a government
that is ideologically we can see what it
is they believe in grow growth only
benefits everybody if everybody gains
but she has no plan to share the
proceeds of that growth she doesn't
believe in redistribution she believes
in raising the cap on Bankers bonuses
but opposing pay Rises that are in line
with inflation for working people it
just doesn't stack up and in the end
that will be the thing that undoes her
unless she changes course before Friday
and we very much hope she does I am Keen
to talk about Ukraine it's such a big
story many of our viewers can be really
concerned about what Ed Putin's been
saying he's called up 300 000 military
reservists it's the biggest mobilization
since World War one would labor be doing
anything differently if you were in
government now we make no apology for
the fact that the political parties in
Britain are united about our response to
Putin we have to stand up to Russian
aggression we have to stand very closely
with our allies in Europe and the United
States and our NATO Partners as well in
order to send a very clear and
unequivocal message to Putin and I
listened to Liz trust today it's a very
welcome change of tack from the approach
that this government has taken for the
last 12 years finally taking Russian
aggression seriously the next bit of
this jigsaw is that they've got to take
seriously the influence of the Russian
government in the United States they've
got to clean up illicit Finance in the
city of London and stop proposing
measures which they've currently got
that they're trying to get through the
statute book to make it easier for
foreign money to influence our politics
would you raise defense spending and I
think it's right to look at defense
spending at the moment you know I
haven't seen the exact details of what
they're proposing but we've always been
very supportive of the idea that you
need to have a baseline of defense
spending which you know until recently
there was a consensus around a minimum
of two percent I think that defense is
one of those things that people often
think is an add-on but look at what is
happening so would you like it to go to
three percent then I think we've got to
make sure that our troops have and our
intelligence Services have exactly what
they need in order to deal with the
threats that we Face we've got a lot of
States at the moment displaying
extremely aggressive behavior in lots of
parts of the world but to have Russia
behaving like this on the edge of our
own neighborhood means that we've got to
take this seriously okay thank you very
much for being on program